aquí arriba tengo escrito un enunciado
que para este vídeo vamos a suponer que
es totalmente cierto vale el enunciado
dice comer espinaca
te vuelve más fuerte para entonces para
este vídeo vamos a suponer que ese
enunciado es totalmente cierto es más
hasta vamos a poner aquí en el dibujito
que si comes espinaca entonces entonces
te vuelves más fuerte vale bueno a
partir de este enunciado queremos
determinar si estos otros enunciados que
escribía aquí se pueden concluir con
este de aquí arriba vale entonces lo que
vamos a hacer es ver si el enunciado
comer espinaca te vuelve más fuerte es
suficiente para concluir cada uno de
estos enunciados bueno vamos con el
primero el primer enunciado dice si
comes espinaca entonces te volverás más
fuerte esto es básicamente lo mismo que
dice el primer enunciado solo que está
en la forma así
entonces sí o sea está poniendo aquí la
condición que es comer espinacas lo
podemos incluso marcar con color naranja
si comes espinaca entonces te volverás
más fuerte que voy a marcar en color
rojo te volverás más fuerte qué es esto
mismo de acá entonces están diciendo
exactamente lo mismo pero con otras
palabras por lo tanto tenemos que el
primer enunciado si se puede concluir a
partir del primero vale bueno vamos al
segundo el segundo enunciado dice si no
comes espinaca entonces no te volverás
más fuerte
ok este de aquí está un poco más
interesante en realidad este enunciado
está asumiendo más de lo que nos dice el
primero verdad el primero nos dice que
comer espinacas una de las formas para
volverse más fuerte pero podría haber
otras formas para volverse más fuerte a
lo mejor no sé hiciste pesas verdad
hiciste pesas y eso se puede hacer más
fuerte o a lo mejor comiste huevo huevo
o no sé a lo mejor tomaste leche
entonces en realidad hay varias formas
con las cuales uno se puede volver más
fuerte que no únicamente es comer
espinaca verdad o sea el primer
enunciado no descarta estas formas de
volver es más fuerte claro nos dice que
comer espinacas una de las formas de
volverse más fuerte pero puede haber
otras entonces no se puede concluir este
segundo verdad si no comes espinaca
entonces no te volverás más fuerte no
necesariamente cierto si no comes
espinaca a lo mejor has espesas o tomas
leche y entonces te podrías volver más
fuerte entonces este segundo enunciado
no se puede concluir a partir del
primero sale bueno vamos al tercero dice
no eres más fuerte así seguro no comiste
espinaca ok aquí tenemos que ponernos en
el papel de lógico es un lógico es una
persona que tiene una lógica muy buena
vale entonces tenemos que pensar con
calma las cosas arriba nos dice que
comer espinacas nos vuelven más fuertes
así a fuerzas entonces tenemos que
separar esto de nuestra experiencia
diaria a lo mejor en la vida diaria pues
no somos más fuertes
y comimos espinaca y podemos pensar que
este no se sigue pero no hay que pensar
así realmente tenemos que asumir el
primer enunciado como totalmente cierto
entonces si comer espinacas a fuerzas
nos vuelven más fuertes entonces si no
nos volvimos más fuertes pues no pudimos
haber comido espinacas porque haberlas
comido nos hubiera vuelto más fuertes
entonces de esta forma este enunciado
también se concluye verdad si no somos
más fuertes
entonces no comimos espinacas porque si
las hubiéramos comido entonces seríamos
más fuertes entonces este de aquí y este
de aquí si se puede deducir a partir del
primero muy bien y finalmente nos dice
eres más fuerte así seguro comiste
espinaca no esté como que no suena bien
verdad suena mucho a esta idea de aquí
arriba que ya platicamos este otra vez
este cuarto enunciado está asumiendo que
la única forma de volverse más fuerte es
es comiendo espinaca pero puede haber
otras formas como hacer pesas o tomar
leche como ya lo platicamos entonces
pues aquí está asumiendo que la única
forma de volverse fuerte
es comiendo espinaca pero eso no dice la
primera y la primera oración verdad dice
que comer espinaca te vuelve más fuerte
o sea si comes espinaca te vuelves más
fuerte te vuelves más fuerte no si solo
si comes espinaca si hay una diferencia
simplemente tenemos este lado entonces
como hay otras formas de volverse más
fuerte este cuarto enunciado no se puede
deducir a partir de el primero a partir
de que comer espinacas te vuelva más
fuerte